really want to head back out there huh
when I first started watching Star Trek
it was so progressive but you realize
it's our world you know it's about this
people from various backgrounds coming
together and deciding to go on a shared
journey into the unknown it's a good
choice
it's just an enduring dream that we
might actually live on into the future
and do something creative and productive
and explore and work together and
tolerate each other it's the idea of an
harmonious future which everybody must
surely one there's only yourself your
ship your crew
I think Star Trek has always represented
a vision of humanity where mankind is
operating at its optimal efficiency and
it has overcome its differences its
conflict and it's about its acceptance
and unity and it's about working
together and exploring space and I think
that it is a vision of humanity that is
inspirational and one that many people
aspire to achieve okay that's never do
that again I always thought like what
happens once you know check off and Sulu
gets off their shift do they go hang out
you know so that was something that rude
the whole original series my love for
the crew extended beyond what would just
on screen you know and so I felt like it
was important on this one to try to kind
of bring some of that on screen we felt
like the Kirk Spock dynamic had been
explored extensively and it was
something we wanted to go let just
simmer for a while and we'll come back
to it later on this time it felt like
let's get into the crew as an ensemble
and not only that let's see other
relationships that exist on the Starship
Enterprise not least Spock and bones
what was very refreshing for me was to
read the script that Simon at Doug wrote
and see what in my opinion is the most
fully realized multi dimensional version
of the character that I've had the
pleasure to play and you know judging by
the early reaction to it audience is a
really warm into that fear of death is
illogical
fear of death is what keeps us alive
we're in 50 years into this franchise
and I felt like it was time to in a way
deconstruct and maybe even challenge
some of the notions of Star Trek some of
the philosophies of Star Trek and and
hopefully by doing that by the end we
will reaffirm why there's so much love
and passion for it
you